ちょっと病気になってしまった。
コンビスじゃない、違うので変なものが流行った。
割と最近だよ。去年ぐらい?
去年?
それにエミスすごく元気でね。
全然病気もしないし、疲れたりもしないのね。
だけど、その病気になっちゃって。
同じお仕事もらえなくなって。
だけど、まだ落ちたんだよ。
去年何が流行ったかな。
今もレタスに入ったバクテリアが流行ったけど。
夏だから、バクテリア病気になりやすい。
アメリカの中だったよ。
日本も大丈夫だけど、他のアジアの国だと、
あんまり流行ったら行けないっていう。
うん、南米も同じ。
そう?
え、なんだろう。大丈夫かな?
え、もう大丈夫?でも、今。
え、みちちゃん。
今、大丈夫?
でも、すごく元気だったんだけど、そうでもなくなったらしい。
あ、そっか。
でも、小さじきは大変だったのよ。
もう、ママがいなかったら泣いちゃうのね。
あ、そう。
ハワイに一度一緒に来たんだけど、何名が入っても全然ダメでね。
え?
ママが、くにくにぽんがちょっと、ちょっとなんか買いに出ちゃって。
うん。
そしたら、みちちゃんのドアのところで、ちょっと、そのまいといて、それに、そうと抱っこして、それで、なんか、絵本か、なんか見て。
えぇ。
日本語もそんなに、よくとは分からなくてね。
え、両方でも、ちょっと、その絵本の話をしたら、少し後で、少しは機嫌を直した。
えぇ。
あ、そうか。
でも、りきみたいに、お料理が上手だったら、もしもし、もし、もしだよ。もし、結婚したらね。
もう、奥様が困っちゃうよね。だって、お主人の方がお料理がすごい上手だったら、いやいやいや。
でも、何作ったってダメじゃない?だから。
いやぁ。
パパパもお料理好きだけど。
そうね。
うん。
パパもお料理好きだったら、そういうのも。